make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking up with deceased
DC's zombies event and in reality I feel
like it was only ever a matter of time
before we saw that I mean to a degree we
got blackest night but blackest night
was more of a Green Lantern event than
it was I mean it did involve all of DC
but that was more of like we're not
doing this for the sake of doing zombies
we're doing this because we want to
bring some characters back and other
characters who want to leave dead right
like blackest night brought back pretty
much everybody who died and then like
brightest day basically kept the ones
they wanted but this is just a
straight-up like zombies event like
that's really all this is it's just like
a straight up DC zombies story and it
starts in one of the coolest ways ever
what this does is it initially picks up
with Darkseid now we get this kind of
like kind of narrative that goes through
they're like you know my mother always
used to say that were there was never
any such thing as monsters and so on but
it's interesting because Tom Taylor's
the one riding this and here's the thing
about Tom Taylor Tom Taylor is really
really good at writing stories that are
basically something akin to like
post-apocalyptic or if like things are
going crazy right like when it comes to
something like this
this is where Tom Taylor really really
really shines and this is kind of cool
because it initially picks up with like
Darkseid invading Earth right like and
you've got it you got some cool
characters here that you wouldn't
normally see like you've got Black
Lightning who's here and then you have
your standard fare of the Justice League
now remember this is like a whole
different universe in DC this is not an
in continuity story as far as I'm aware
it's some it's basically like a what-if
story for Marvel so because of that some
of the characters do look a little bit
different but you basically have
Darkseid showing up here in like the
Justice League defeats him right which
is what you would expect right I mean
usually whenever Darkseid shows up it's
kind of like the Justice League fights
them for a little bit and they defeat
him and that's basically the end of that
what's kind of ironic about this and
this is kind of a funny thing was kind
of ironic about this is remember in the
DC multiverse there's only one Darkseid
and he's currently in Justice League
Odyssey so this is one of those
scenarios we just kind of have to just
go with it and just say what the heck
ever you know I mean like if you're a
huge continuity stickler well then I
don't know what to tell you but it is
kind of cool because when they of course
Wonder Woman gets the last bit of truth
around Darkseid and the way this works
is that those individuals who are bound
by the lasso are usually like they're
forced to answer whatever question
Wonder Woman asks truthfully right and
there's usually week not really week but
they're usually like helpless within the
confines of the lasso with Darkseid
though the same it is like you will not
return to our world say it the last so
compels you to and Darkseid says yes I'm
not going to come back for your world
and then he just removes the lasso and
it's like because I have what I
aim for literally darkside overpowers
the lasso of truth which is cool but
from there we end up finding out that
like no one can find cyborg cyborg was
in Metropolis at one point along the
line he was basically helping till I
deal with all the parademons and all the
kind of stuff that came with like
Darkseid's invasion but nobody knows
where cyborg is anymore and that's
presumably what Darkseid came for now
what are the cool little things that go
on here this is kind of important is a
little bit of character building this is
one of those is why I say that that Tom
Taylor is really good at this Tom Taylor
is very good at capturing the nature of
characters and no matter what story
they're in making sure they stay true
right like Batman is a guy who doesn't
trust anyone and so it's almost Howard
babble esque in the sense that like
Batman pulls up his device that says
like like cyborgs nowhere around here
they're like well how do you know that
is it because I put a tracking device on
because the guys got apocalypta and
technology's basically like a walking
mother box he's essentially like a crazy
weapon it'd be stupid to leave him here
and there's a bit of distrust that comes
to the rest of the Justice League like
really man you're still doing this after
all this time but it makes sense it's
the nature of Batman's character now
from here we switch over to apocalypse
properly I remember Apocalypse is a is a
is a world of pain and suffering is
really all it is it's the equivalent of
Hell in the realm of DC right like
you've got highfather on new Genesis
which is supposed to be equivalent to
heaven but my father's kind of a dick
and then you have apocalypse which is
supposed to be something akin to hell
they're not it's not actually heaven in
hell those do exist in NBC and the
vertical line but in terms of the main
DC superheroes which you never really
see that the concept of like vertigo
with like the presents and then Lucifer
Morningstar in those characters because
you never see them crossover with the
main DC superheroes they're largely
considered to be kind of isolated and on
their own even though they're really not
and so because of that apocalypse inand
new Genesis is about as close as you get
to heaven in Hell but because this is a
place of suffering and torment it's
literally cyborgs being hooked up to a
torture machine
and then basically being asked questions
and this is where the revelation comes
from that what Darkseid had been
pursuing was the same thing he always
been pursuing which is the anti-life
equation now again Tom Taylor really
like kind of knocking it out of the park
here it's designed to read it to bring
in new readers people who have never
really read DC and specifically have not
really read anything about the new gods
won't know what the anti-life equation
is the anti-life equation is a
mathematical proof that if you can
basically find it and and if you can use
it you can dominate the will of all
sentient beings in the universe it's
what dark sides always been hunting for
is what he found during the events of
Final Crisis like it's it's a
major part of the the DC landscape now
but where Darkseid has had one half of
the equation which is to say if you were
to use slope the equation y equals MX
plus B then what dark side basically has
is MX plus B he doesn't have Y and so
what he's doing is looking for the other
half of the equation he's looking for y
and it seems to have manifested itself
inside of Cyborg now the nature of the
anti-life equation is kind of strange
right like the equation is is its little
it's it is a mathematical proof but it
can also is it's also sort of a
biological concept if you solve it and
use it it has a tangible effect and
it'll spread like a virus and that's
exactly what happens dark side basically
takes the anti-life equation and then he
in turn summons death and then in doing
so summoning the black racer he
basically takes a portion he takes the
anti-life equation and merges it with an
aspect of death essentially like I guess
maybe this twisted perception that the
anti-life equation can be used to kill
everyone but because of that because the
anti-life equation has been merged with
death it basically corrupts the equation
and when it does it sends dark side
spiraling out well he just basically
loses his mind and succumbs to absolute
and pure madness and like the little
black racers like time for God to die
and desaad because of the fact that he's
basically immune to any kind of viruses
or anything like that any kind of
disease he's not infected by by
basically this corrupted anti-life
equation but in realizing what it's
doing the dark side sends cyborg away in
hopes a little basically fixed dark side
now of course this sends cyborg back to
earth but at the same time dark side
loses mind and then destroys the
entirety of apocalypse and wipes all of
it out and so when cyborg lands back on
earth he brings the corrupted anti-life
equation with him and that's how the
zombie infection spreads it's actually a
genius idea a virus that's designed to
bend others to its will and then in turn
merge it with death basically bends
others to its well and turns them into
the walking dead it is super fool and
it's a it really really works but kind
of drawing from the final crisis because
of the fact that the anti-life equation
is a mathematical proof and because of
the fact that cyborg is a walking
talking cybernetic organism that
basically taps into the internet the
anti-life equation of the corrupted
equation basically leaves him and goes
into the internet it turns into Skynet
and literally spreads everywhere it goes
all over the place at every single form
of social media to everybody's phones
spreads like wildfire so it's very
similar to what you saw in spreading the
anti-life equation and final crisis
which again makes sense but because of
the fact of the world is so
logged into social media those looking
at Twitter Instagram snapchat Facebook
the whole nine yards are all basically
blasted with this virus and in turn are
basically hit with like the corrupted
version of the anti-life equation and in
doing so like they all basically just
succumb to like these zombie monster
things but basically cyborg is the one
that starts off the the sets off the
whole zombie apocalypse but it's kind of
interesting here because in turn like
you have Superman talking to Scott free
talking to big Barda of course you know
mister miracle and basically saying hey
look guys like you know we got to find
cyborg so on a soft but in the middle of
all that he basically takes off because
all he hears is screaming only to
realize like it's this whole virus thing
is spread across the world now Superman
doesn't initially know why all this is
happening and it's it's one of these
things that Tom Taylor kind of passes
over right like that's that's one of the
downsides of Tom Taylor Tom Taylor can
like hop skip and jump from point to
point to point and not fill in the gaps
and then kind of leave you asking
questions of will but like how though
and like what seems to have happened is
between the times like Superman went out
there and the world was screaming and
the time that we pick up with Jonathan
Lois and Damian Wayne that basically
Superman figured out that this virus is
being spread digitally now we can kind
of make some assumptions here so maybe
like in this universe Final Crisis
happened and like Superman says okay
this seems to be like the the anti-life
equation straining through the digital
sphere like you did in Final Crisis it
could be Superman just like analyzing
these guys using whatever vision he has
but but regardless of the scenario
Superman comes to the realization that
it's spreading through TV and social
media and so of course we have Jonathan
going to find his mom's phone and so on
and so forth as soon as he picks it up
Superman destroys it when he flies him
through the window and then destroys the
TV screen it says nobody look at
anything everybody close your eyes chill
everybody relax
from there you switch over to Batman and
this is one of the coolest parts so
Batman you know being the detective that
he is is already on the case right like
Gotham's basically is lost
Batman shuts down like like the entire
connection of Wayne Manor to the
Internet's to the Batcave is not
connected to any of the Internet in turn
he has all these all these redundant
loops he's got Gotham City on close to
some cameras so basically he shuts
himself off from the world and then in
turn starts analyzing all the footage
that he sees and realizes like the whole
places go into pot and when the question
is how many people are infected right
now an estimated 600 million people have
been affected in the first day the
entire world's population will be
infected in a couple days and basically
that's it it's game over and it's cool
because from there Batman basically
issues like the EMP for Wayne Manor
shuts down the power to
Emin is is essentially just kind of
walking blind but technology has become
the enemy of the world and that's one of
the cool things about about Tom Taylor
is there's always kind of a moral tale
right I mean Grant Morrison is similar
to that and I bring him up because of
the you know we've been talking about
Final Crisis the problems Grant Morrison
is nobody understands what Grant
Morrison is doing except for himself and
people who are fans who think they know
what Grant Morrison is doing there's you
know whatever but but regardless of the
circumstance like there's always kind of
a moral cautionary tale when it comes to
Tom Taylor stories and it's the like the
Internet is the enemy of the world like
social media is the enemy of the world
which technically he's not wrong but
what you end up having is like this this
kind of discussion between Lois and
Superman Damian and and Jonathan and
there's like worse Batman like is Batman
gonna make it this is kind of cool to
see because one of the things that that
really sort of made Amiens such an
interesting character is that while he
is cold blooded and ruthless and in his
insanely talented killer the fact
remains he's still a kid and it's cool
to see that that child part of them come
out he's worried about his dad is my dad
going to be okay I love the way that's
done and so what you end up doing is
basically picking up with like Batman
kind of making his way through Wayne
Manor and looking for Alfred and looking
for Tim Drake no I'm sorry did dick is
who he's looking for Tim Drake who he's
also looking for but what Batman is of
finding like once he finds Alfred who
thankfully is okay Dick Grayson is not
Dick Grayson has been turned into a
zombie so basically we have Batman
versus zombie Dick Grayson and it's kind
of cool it's pretty awesome to see
though in the middle is whole fight
where you have de Grayson suddenly
you're met with the arrival of like Tim
Drake and so basically you've got zombie
Tim Drake you've got zombie Dick Grayson
Batman's made to face off against the
both of them
he tells Alfred to run for his life and
like the last thing we see is Dick
Grayson taking a chunk out of Batman's
neck Dick Grayson kills Batman
okay so picking up with deceased number
two this story is do this story is so
good here's the thing about Tom Taylor
writing man Tom Taylor writing is legit
like it's one okay Tom Taylor's really
really good at writing like dark stories
right it's just like things are popping
off and people are dying get Tom Taylor
to ride it like Tom Taylor's really good
at that I would not give like Captain
America at his hometown although it
probably would be a pretty cool story be
dark but it'd be probably a pretty cool
story okay so many more upbeat somebody
more light heart right like I would not
give a spider-man story to Tom Taylor
there we go like I wouldn't I wouldn't
give spider-man a Tom Taylor um because
you would write a pretty dark spider-man
story uh but the world's ending because
like cyborg released a virus onto the
world like blood was a carrier for the
anti-life equation which spread through
technology yeah man let Tom Taylor write
that story and it's not exactly the way
you would expect because again from the
first video that we saw that's basically
what's happening right like Darkseid who
- since they found the anti-life
equation and the dark side was corrupted
by this sort of twisted version of the
anti-life equation that he that he
essentially created and then in turn
with cyborg being a carrier for it
cyborg was kind of teleported back to
earth when like Darkseid became
corrupted went crazy and everything and
then cyber war released it into the
internet right like release it over the
digital space which basically is kinda
like this digital virus right so for
those you guys who saw who who ever read
a cellular I think was called cellular
by uh by Stephen King that's basically
it right like a virus it spreads
throughout the world using digital
information and it works exceedingly
well and that's one of the things I like
about this right like if this was a
direct copy of Marvel Zombies well then
something something something something
now we have zombies people are being
bitten and they're turning into zombies
right but like that's been done before
what better way to create a kind of
zombie story more or less then to like
have it spread through the internet like
we saw in Final Crisis it's a great way
to do it it's a really cool concept and
so in this one we basically pick up in
the middle of the Atlantic Ocean with
Aquaman and all the bands just kinda
like okay she's like there's a boat out
here in the middle of nowhere and like
cargos dumping everywhere and like these
are popping off what in the world's
happening and like when he opens this
this door of the ship in the hole
there's like monsters everywhere and
Aquaman just flees for his life this is
kind of cool because what this does is
it begs the question can Atlantis be
affected right because like what you're
talking and we'll talk more about this
here once we get towards the end of the
video because Tom Taylor kind of
indirectly answers that question
ah but with Atlantis being so far below
the surface
and in a lot of ways being in a place
where you kind of have to wear like a
pressurized suit otherwise this shear
pressure would probably crush you it's a
question of like can people make it down
there with no protection whatsoever in
order to successfully infiltrate the
place but at this point we kind of jump
over to Metropolis right and so you got
Jonathan Kent you've got Damian Wayne
you've got Lois Lane and you've got
Superman all right now again they're
kind of picking up in the middle of all
this and that's the nature of this whole
thing remember it spreads so far so fast
like it was like Skynet going live in
the blink of an eye this virus was all
over the world and just like everything
is kind of falling all at the same time
but it also restricts their ability to
be able to access it to be able to speak
to different people right like Lois
Lane's response is we have to go to the
Daily Planet but our our first
inclination is that won't do you any
good because it's being spread to the
digital space so anybody who picks up
like a cellular phone or anything that's
connected to the Internet like a
smartphone or something like that
they're gonna be infected by this
anti-life equation so so you need
something like a rotary phone right like
you need something it's like old hat
technology analog information so it's
kind of a cool little thing because
presumably the Daily Planet has that now
the other half of this is of course
Damian Wayne's freaking out of her
Batman that's one thing I want you guys
to notice is this story of course takes
place in it doesn't take place in the
main DC continuity but it does include
the characters as they exist right now
right like Damian Wayne's a little bit
older Jonathan Kent is of course older
there's a couple steps that we can take
to sort of make this fit in the sense of
like we can kind of assume that things
haven't progressed the exact same way
right like Jonathan was not taken by his
grandfather into space and then aged up
we can assume a lot of those things
didn't happen so like Bendis you know
this the bit misses version of Superman
doesn't take place in this universe and
said they just kind of aged up
accordingly right there is some number
of years older than they normally are
and we can just kind of call it a day
right like we just sort of take those
those lenience 'iz and and be done with
it but it's weird you go over to Harley
Quinn this is an important thing because
what this shows is not everyone's aware
of what's going on and and for the most
part even those who are aware what's
going on don't really seem to have the
full understanding of what's happening
right like picking up with Harley Quinn
and poison ivy there's no indication
here that like zombies are infecting
everything or anything like that they're
just kind of having a general
conversation Poison Ivy's like hey you
got to go in there and you got to do
your thing when you come out I'll be
waiting for you in the Botanic Gardens
everything's gonna be okay Harley Quinn
has no real idea of what's going on and
neither seemingly does poison ivy and so
when Harley Quinn walks into this room
we of course realize she's talking to
the joke she's like hey I came here to
tell you I'm running off with poison ivy
I'm leaving here
and I'm never coming back our life
together is over and it's at that point
that we find out that Joker has
basically been turned into one of these
zombies now here's the cool question to
be asked here here's here's the cool
question we need to ask you if the Joker
is one of these zombie monsters is there
any real difference like that's the cool
question to ask and I guess it depends
on which version the Joker you're
talking about right like if you're
talking about Steve Englehart Joker
right like the version that Batman the
Animated Series was based off of then
yeah you probably see a pretty big
difference but if we're talking about
like Scott Snyder new 52 death in the
family Joker flight or death of the
family Joker like honestly I don't know
if you'd see that huge of a difference
you would just see more crazy than usual
now here's the thing I want to see I
want to see zombie Joker versus the
Batman who lost that's what I want to
see let me tell you something dude I
would I would pay I'd pay however much
money DC is charging to read that one
shot aw dude a baby like it's $100 to
read this and I would be like here you
go
like I just take my money I wouldn't
even care it would be it'd be amazing to
see but in this moment Joker's basically
infected by this virus more or less and
is presumably gonna tear apart Harley
Quinn and so from here we actually shift
over what to what I think is one of the
coolest moments in the entire the entire
story when we pick up outside of
Metropolis now again this is kind of an
important thing to bear in mind here
unless you're in a major city you for
the most part don't really know what's
going on and that makes the most sense
right I mean those individuals who were
in like major metropolitan areas are
usually tapped in more in the digital
space but those who were in like
outlying rural territories right I mean
as a guy who lived in Kentucky Lexington
and Louisville are the two biggest
cities and so everything outside of that
you got rich man you got Winchester
Versailles Harrodsburg and then you go
out further and you run into places like
Rockcastle County and things like that
and the further out you go and even the
closer you go east to the Appalachian
Mountains the less technologically
advanced people become and so when you
when you're in that kind of an
environment when you're further out and
you're not tapped into the digital space
at the time that this goes down you have
no idea what's going on because you're
so far removed from the environment
around you now you would kind of expect
that like the various explosions that
we're hearing and/or seeing and things
like that a metropolis at the very least
that noise would reach the ear of like
Black Canary and in an Oliver Queen
Green Arrow and Hal Jordan you would
expect that it would reach them but for
whatever reason it has it may be that is
so far outside of metropolis but they're
not really picking up on it but the cool
thing is were kind of going back and
forth and having their own little banter
and it's actually kind of a cool tip of
the nod and the reason why is because if
you're not really familiar with the
history of Green Lantern Green Arrow it
doesn't really resonate with you
but for those people who do there's a
lot of not really callbacks but just
kind of a great little bit of nostalgia
here right because like Green Lantern
and green arrow those two guys were
brought together because their comics
weren't really selling and so DC merged
them together and basically put them in
a singular story it was essentially a
team-up book for like a number of years
and here's a funny thing is it was
actually incredibly popular like it was
it was insanely popular you wouldn't
expect it to be but it was oh it was
hugely popular and people loved it
because of the dynamic while you had the
joking nature of Oliver Queen combined
with the more serious tone of Hal Jordan
and you've got some great stories by
Neal Adams and Dennis O'Neil right like
snow birds don't fly different things
like that but again these guys have been
exceedingly good friends for a very very
long time and so that's why it's kind of
cool to see them paired together so for
people who are fans of Green Arrow and
Green Lantern they kind of look at this
and they say hey this is a cool little
throwback a cool little tip with a nod
to the to the old stories from
yesteryear but of course you know
they're also kind of giving Howard a
hard time because he's so serious all
the time so like you're like the killjoy
right like like Oliver Queen jumps up
and he was like he's like Hal Jordon you
have the ability to suck the fun out of
every situation
welcome to the killjoy Court which in
all honesty I kind of want to see that
right like just a bunch of cynical jerks
just going around and just being like I
don't enjoy anything and nothing's fun
or happy and I just complain about
everything all the time so basically
like a huge portion of Twitter right
like the killjoy court so it's like I
think it'd be funny like I think it'd be
kind of interesting right just like like
this this little mini series where's
just a bunch of like okay that's what
you do you just like basically make it
like people on Twitter right people who
are just like you know I just want to be
upset about something so I'm just going
to tweet about things that I'm angry
about and hope that somebody listens and
hope that I can fix my life even though
I can't not by tweeting on Twitter but
like I want to see like that that mini
series just focuses on them right like
just some keyboard warrior at home
trying to change the world from a lounge
chair I really want to see it I really
want to see that story I think it would
be hilarious but nonetheless uh you know
what's Hal Jordan actually like goes
into his tent that's when everything
begins to go crazy right because it was
just like okay so he gets on his phone
and of course she's immediately hit with
the virus and then starts losing his
mind
and then like busts out so what we've
got is basically like this zombified Hal
Jordan as a Green Lantern wielding the
power of a Green Lantern a zombie Green
Lantern it's the coolest thing ever
in a lot of ways he almost reminds me of
like a combination of the Sinestro Corps
and the Red Lanterns right because like
the ring immediately says like lethal
force is a lethal force is not is not
sanctioned right so like
you cannot kill people now here's a
funny thing is it almost kind of seems
like Sinestro Corps war never happened
right because Sinestro Corps war is when
things change and the Green Lantern's
could start killing people so presumably
like Sinestro doesn't exist the Sinestro
Corps war never took place
whatever the case says Green Lantern's
can't kill folks and so it's kind of
crazy because like he's trying to kill
them now here's where the big saving
grace comes in because then you've got
like Oliver Queen who's basically
attacked by Hal Jordan tell Jordan ghost
to kill him and then Dinah Lance the
Black Canary just like screams in the
face of Hal Jordan and just like
destroys his eardrums and it's a crazy
thing because like it basically like
Dino scrambles his brains and it kills
him and then it's Hal Jordan Green
Lantern of sector to eight one four
deceased scanning for replacement
replacement found Dinah Lance of Earth
you have the ability to overcome great
fear
welcome to the Green Lantern's and it's
just like wow like it's the coolest
thing never in my life did I think it
would be cool to see Black Canary become
a Green Lantern but I'm excited about
that because imagine what she can do
with hardlight constructs and a sonic
scream I'm really excited by it right I
mean you can tell there's obvious
influence from injustice in this story
right like taking someone set of powers
and throwing it onto somebody else that
you at least expect and then just kind
of see how things play out there's
obviously a lot of injustice going on in
terms of how the story is being written
but it's it's it's really really awesome
now of course once you end up having
Superman and company Superman Damian
Jonathan and Lois showing up at the
Daily Planet it's exactly what we would
expect right you know Superman's like
hey stay here this place is filled with
monsters so basically you know from from
what house it may responds to Lois this
question is that people we know Superman
of course looks at and says yes so we
can assume Perry White we can assume
Jimmy Olsen we can assume a lot of the
people who have traditionally been the
supporting cast of the Superman comics
are essentially infected and and they're
they're you know they're caught up by
this virus and so with us this cool
thing happening Superman of course does
the one thing you're never supposed to
do I'll be right back which usually
never happens that's never usually the
case but of course the reason why he
takes off is not to go into the Daily
Planet it's because he heard a scream
and that's when he races over any ends
up realizing that like hey like Black
Canary is the Green Lantern we need you
to have these powers like we need you
with us you have to come along here and
so with that in mind like with of course
Black Canary in tow bringing Oliver
Queen they all basically show up here at
you know they kind of reach her in to
the Daily Planet and that's when Batman
chimes in and it's like okay so Batman
basically says hey look they're not
really zombies in the traditional sense
they don't desire to consume
flush they're basically the anti-life
right like these are individuals who
have been infected with the anti-life
equation all they want to do is spread
this anti life right so it's kind of
saying they're dead but they're not dead
it's interesting because what Tom's
healer really kind of seems to indicate
here there may be a way to bring them
back but what Batman what he really does
is kind of clear that up right off the
bat when Batman says you can't cure them
there's no way to bring them back those
individuals that we lost are now gone
whatever percentage of the world's
population is infected is now infected
forever and so if you're not tapped into
a phone and you're bitten by one of
these guys you are now infected with
anti your life and the only way to
basically deal with you is to kill you
so in a sense they are basically zombies
just by a different name right Lee the
only female AK is just consuming flesh
they're zombies under a different
circumstance but again this is actually
a pretty sad moment because you've got
of course got Alfred standing by with a
shotgun and you've got Batman in the
suit of mr. freeze basically cooling his
body down slowing his metabolism and
keeping the virus from like over running
him but he basically says like there's
no cure for there's nothing I can do
here like I am going to die like I'm
going to become one of those things
there's no way for me to kind of go back
to who I was and there's almost like
some doubt here right I mean Oliver
Queen she's like no no no you're Batman
do you like Oliver Queen is like the
voice of the fan right he's like no
you're Batman do you like you have prep
time or you know some fill in the blank
reason but like you always come back
from this and it's kind of cool because
Batman doesn't have prep time because
Batman is not prepared for it which of
course always answers the question what
happens when Batman doesn't have prep
time he dies so it's kind of a cool
little thing here like it's kind of a
cool little moment of like Batman based
like like the world like everybody's
saying goodbye to Batman saying like you
know there's no way we can bring you
back and this is this was a really
touching moment because Batman didn't
start talking to Damian and he's like
hey look like Alfred has something for
you is something I always left for you I
knew you would earn it notice this is
something Batman doesn't say Batman
doesn't say I love you son like he
doesn't he doesn't say you know I I love
you you know you're my son
you know I'm he do you of course
residents um he doesn't really say like
I love you and and I always will or
something along those lines you don't
really see that kind of tender moment
right you just kind of see Batman being
Batman worse like I left something for
you you would have earned it one day
anyway you would have taken this up
which of course we know that it's
basically the bat suit that Damian Wayne
is going to become Batman and so it's
kind of a crazy theme because of course
at that point in time
- when Bruce begins to switch Riley
that's what he starts to turn into this
zombified version and it's the craziest
thing because Alfred does the only thing
he can do he says cease transmission it
never should have interviewed this way
I'm sorry son and then there's a shotgun
fire
okay so picking up with a deceased part
3 this was actually kind of sad we
talked about this in our injustice
videos right and we even talked about in
the first the first video or so of
deceased that when it comes to Tom
Taylor as a writer
while his stories can be exceedingly
dark Tom Taylor is very very good at
drawing out the human element of
characters as well this is why I love
Alex Ross art so much to kind of go off
on a tangent for a second you look at
like the Alex Ross drawing of like the
Justice League or like the JSA or
something like that and it almost makes
you nostalgic for an era of comics that
none of us were really part of when like
there were good guys and bad guys and
like that was it
but it was more like the people behind
the characters it's why the world's
greatest superheroes I think is the
greatest comic book miniseries of all
time and this picks up essentially with
Alfred just kind of saying his goodbyes
to some of the bat family right so it's
like Tim Drake and to Batman and to
degres him because all three of them are
dead and whenever we read stories like
this when characters die you know
depending on how attached we are there's
always like that one part of us that
would that kind of wishes they were
still there right like the kind of kind
of holds out hope that like they'll come
back you know and it's kind of
interesting because it's like okay well
maybe we missed something maybe they're
not really dead you know maybe they're
just like recovering or like Batman's
healing or something but like something
has to happen that they come back and
Tom Taylor just kind of seems to put off
this indication of like no they're gone
Alfred basically takes you know the the
batwing and like leaves but the cool
thing about this and one of the reasons
why I like that so much is because this
puts off the indication and it really
shows how bleak things are that like
heroes are dying left and right and
they're not coming back and it's kind of
the cool thing because well this is only
really six issues long just from what
I've seen so far I feel like it could be
longer I mean anything more than nine I
think you would stretch on too much but
from what we saw with flight what is it
Batman the white knight like six issue
miniseries can lead into something
better which is what we're getting right
we're getting a sequel to that too the
white knight this looks really really
awesome and so switching over to Harley
Quinn like it's kind of a bit of a
moment for her right I mean when it
comes to Harley and DC Comics this is
one of the things that I've always kind
of struggled with with her characters
when it comes to Harley in DC Comics
when she first popped up she was
basically kind of a holdover from Batman
the Animated Series right that's where
she originally appeared that's where she
got her debut and there wasn't really a
whole lot of development there it wasn't
until a few years went by the DC saw me
is sort of finally focusing and building
on Harley and then of course later on
added her to the Suicide Squad and
different things like that but the idea
behind this is that her character has
always for a
long time sort of existed under the
shadow of the Joker that's what she was
best known for but for the for her
character inside the comics she's under
the shadow of Joker right like he's the
guy who taunts her he's the guy that
makes your life a living hell
and the guy she always goes back to you
and so where she's always kind of tried
to make an escape in this one we get a
kind of finality here right I mean the
Joker is is is zombified right him he's
a zombified version the Joker he's a
zombie Harley Quinn like grabs a shotgun
and like blows him in half right just
like shoots him and kills him or at
least you know seems to kill him now one
of the things that that haven't really
been it hasn't really been established
here by Tom Taylor at least not outright
specifically is that if a person has
kind of turned into one of these
quote-unquote zombies which he's kind of
sitting there not really zombies but
they basically are if a person's turn
into a zombie and then in turn like they
are killed by traditional means can they
come back and I don't think that's
explicitly been stated yet right I mean
a person can be turned into a zombie but
but there's no indication they can
actually come back from that if they've
been killed but still like it at the
moment right now the Joker is just kind
of shot and killed and that seems to be
the end of that and then Harley's met by
the birds of prey right so like Huntress
and Catwoman and bat woman and Batgirl
so basically like a majority of the
superhero community are now being turned
into these zombie things and that's why
I say it's so cool it's because
everybody's back really seems to be up
against the wall it's the end times
right like things are falling apart
it almost kind of seems like a
fast-tracked version of injustice right
I mean and just as you know things pop
off the Joker kills or really tricked
Superman into killing Lois and their
unborn child a bomb gets blown up or you
know is detonated and wipes out
metropolis and then over the course of
like an entire year or really two years
depending on how you want to look at it
Superman goes from like this guy who was
a superhero to like a a full-on villain
and so it's kind of a cool thing because
you look at that and it's like
fast-tracked right it's like things are
falling apart things are basically
breaking apart exceedingly fast but it
works because if this were to happen and
if some kind of zombie plague were to
manifest and be spread through digital
information then it would happen this
fast right I mean as office people are
on their phones surfing the web looking
at YouTube videos different things like
that people are constantly wired and and
connected and so if there if there were
some kind of digital virus they could
convert people into like these monstrous
zombie things it would happen like that
that the world would be conquered within
a day and a half
only rural villages and towns would be
the ones would be the last affected
because they're really more disconnected
than than like major metropolitan areas
but again it's a cool thing and so
switching over to Damien this is a part
of him that we usually never get to see
when you have Damien like he's basically
facing the fact that like
his father's debt and for Damian Wayne
historically speaking as a character
he's almost seemed disconnected from his
own humanity right I mean he was
basically conceived by Talia al Ghul and
basically like a pretty screwed up
scenario with Batman and then in turn
like raise among the the League of
Assassins and then basically taught to
be like this / digis Killer right like
the human element was never really part
of it he was just taught to kill and it
wasn't until he was brought to Batman
and raised by Bruce that Bruce tried to
instill that human element in him right
it's the nature of the progression of
his character going from what was
essentially a killing machine to
becoming a killing machine who's also
human and so because of that because we
never really get to see this kind of
moment in him it's actually pretty
touching because Jonathan sits down with
him and where Damian Wayne doesn't want
to talk Jonathas response is okay well
then I'll go ahead and just sit here so
that you don't have to be alone it's a
very important thing and on the surface
it kind of seems like okay well that's
interesting this is probably one of the
most important displays of friendship
that Jonathan's ever shown to Damian and
the reason why is because sometimes it's
not all about just being there and like
giving the right answers all the time
and saving it it's saying everything you
need to say they just make a person feel
better
sometimes it's just being there like the
knowledge of you being there is enough
and that's all they need all they need
is to know that you're there and that's
that's it that's that's the only comfort
they need everything else they can deal
with internally and when the time comes
when they're ready to talk they will
it's a very important life lesson that I
think not a few people not enough people
learned being there is important that's
the most important thing so again you
know you have Superman you have Lois who
actually stay hands off the same thing
with with Oliver Queen and with Dinah
Lance they kind of stay hands off and
they're like we'll just leave them there
and we'll just let them be friends and
whatever happens happens it's a really
really cool moment but Superman's
response is also kind of focusing on
other things because he kind of keeps
mulling over him to himself you know how
Damien's feeling Damian just lost his
dad and then it clicks
Superman's responses I have to go home I
have to go to Smallville and initially
it's kind of like okay you know Lois is
like okay I understand you have to do
that but Superman is kind of like okay
what what we need to do is create a safe
space for you guys and this is the this
is one of the coolest moments in the
story because when this happened
Superman uses his x-ray vision he looks
throughout the entirety of the Daily
Planet and he has to differentiate
between who's infected and who's not and
what he says here is that those who are
infected cannot be brought back and so
he has to stop looking at them like
they're human beings and look at them
strictly as the enemy and that's a
crushing thing for Superman to have to
do right because he's the guy who always
sees the best in things who always sees
hope Superman
and bodies hook and to suddenly thrust
himself into a position where he has to
look at people and say there is no hope
is devastating their people he's worked
with for years you know Jimmy Jimmy
Olsen like Perry White their family and
so with that being the case it's
literally him having to eliminate his
own family members because there's no
way to save them it's it's an absolutely
devastating role to have to take on the
hardest part of this whole situation is
separating himself from his own humanity
it's the hardest thing to do and it's so
cool to see it done that way right I
mean it's things like this he's kind of
cool introspective deconstructive
stories with Superman in them that make
him more interesting right I mean
because Superman is easily original
superhero he flies he punches that's not
interesting what makes it interesting is
when you focus on him as a character in
these scenarios where he has to kind of
cast aside everything he's known and
become something different even if only
for a brief amount of time it's a cool
little moment here because then you
switch over to Atlantis and you've got
Mara and then you've got Darth burning
how to use his powers as tempest or at
least controlling them in a more finite
level and Mara being the one to teach
him right but remember Atlantis is for
the most part isolated from the surface
world
and aside from Aquaman neo realizes it
like the surface is going to pot and we
haven't see what he's been doing nobody
else in Atlantis knows what's going on
there's no reason for them to be
concerned but it's suddenly in the midst
of all this the water starts turning
dark and for me it was it was kind of
confusing for us I don't like why in the
world is the water turning dark like you
know and it was kind of wild because
when that happened like you literally
find out that what Aquaman's been doing
is attacking and killing everyone not
only that like Aquaman presumably has
been attacking like animal sharks and
things like that because they're now
consuming people either that or Aquaman
is sending out like subtle commands to
the shark saying like kill everyone so
like it could be one of the other but
literally like this is all just blood in
the water and that's what Maher says
like stay away from the blood like do
not make contact with the blood but for
Garth it's too late
and so with Mary using her powers to
essentially control water she makes her
escape and it's actually kind of a cool
little theme because what she could do
here it's create a kind of safe pocket
around herself everywhere she goes but
remember Mira's powers can be mentally
exhausting she's gonna have to make her
way to the surface she's gonna have to
seek out what's left of the superheroes
but when she gets to the surface then
she's gonna realize how dire things are
that the world is essentially over as it
was kind of cool because the Superman
making his way one of the things he says
is like like for him as a hero his job
is to be there for as many people as he
can but the problem he faces right now
is that like everyone needs him and so
of course he comes across black
lightning it comes across yet comes
across Jefferson Pierce Jefferson Pierce
is actually kind of cool you never
really
him that much and like these crossover
events I mean I think it's really he's
more pronounced now than he has been
before because he's got his own show
it was Jefferson Pierce is kind of
interesting it's kind of a combination
of like like innate abilities or not
really innate abilities but like
abilities unto himself as well as using
like some kind of magic and mysticism to
create like black lightning but still
it's kind of cool with this whole thing
because when he shows up like it's
basically him fighting fighting Clayface
because Clayface is infected and is like
turning in like this giant tentacle
monster like attacking everything in
sight we only see Jefferson Pierce for a
short amount of time but it is kind of
cool because you get to see they're like
hey look there's some guys here one of
the things that I dig about this is that
this almost kind of feels like a movie
is an interesting little scenario but
when he gets back home to Smallville of
course he's met by his mother Martha and
she's like your father's inside I hit
him over the head something's wrong with
him and then of course when Superman
gets in there it turns out that his
father's infected now this kind of makes
sense the idea of Jonathan of Jonathan
Kent dying it's part and parcel to his
character right I mean it's what happens
with him and so when you have this
scenario and for where like Superman
gets home and like his father's infected
it's one of the most touching moments in
the story because usually whenever
Jonathan Kent died he was circumstances
outside of Superman's control right like
either he wasn't there or it was
something that he couldn't have helped
whatever the case was whether it was in
like the Man of Steel movie where he
gets whisked away by a tornado and which
of course is a result of him making one
of the dumbest decisions ever like hey
son like rescue them and rescue me
because you're super fast and you could
easily do it no just stay there and
don't save me because the world doesn't
need to know you exist okay I'm pretty
sure that if Superman was like hey look
guys I really had to do this I had to
rescue my dad please just don't tell
anybody who I am and it would be like
yeah man we understand dude like it's
cool I'm pretty sure they wouldn't run
off to the paper and say hey man there's
this guy who can fly in in like
Smallville uh you guys should definitely
write a report about it it was it was
clearly like terrible writing on behalf
of Zack Snyder which is what he usually
does but but nonetheless like his father
normally dies right and so like in those
circumstances where it's outside
Superman's control and this circumstance
it is like Superman literally has to put
his you put his humanity aside in the
most extreme scenario ever and say okay
like my father's here I'm going to leave
him here you would expect like what I
would have expected is that he would
have killed him I know what a lot of
people would have disagreed with that
and a lot of people would have said no
that's dumb that's stupid you know yadda
yadda so on and so forth I think it
would have been awesome because it would
have been really one of these moments it
really kind of doesn't really snap
Superman but really shows how dire
things are this Superman has to kill his
own pops but leaving
Smallville and leaving him there it kind
of you know leaving him confined down in
there unless he has a strength to break
out which he doesn't Superman basically
sealed it closed with us with his heat
vision it kind of works because assuming
that he didn't find a way out then he
would just be kind of stuck down there
forever
but if he did find a way out well then
there goes Smallville like everybody and
Smallville is gonna be a be infected so
potentially Superman's doomed his entire
hometown assuming they weren't really
dead already
but it's kind of a cool thing it's a
it's a it's a cool moment like this
story's awesome and I think it's a lot
better than people are giving it credit
any credit for okay so we're picking up
with DC's part four and I feel like
Captain Atom fans are gonna be a little
bit pissed because this actually reminds
me of Kingdom Come if I'm being honest
with you guys it reminds me a lot of
Kingdom Come so deceased as we know is
basically the anti-life equation turned
into a viral form this infected the
world and it was cool to see it used
this way but like the only real
implementation that we saw with the
anti-life equation being used on a
global scale was during Final Crisis and
it was really more just like taking the
will away from people but weaponizing it
and turning it into a system to where it
basically creates zombies more or less
is actually pretty intriguing now we
will get some clarification in terms of
what all this is and how it works but
again this sort of switches over to
captain Adam and again captain Adams
always kind of just been like a
government man you know kind of part of
Cadmus and all that kind of stuff
basically like a government guy but what
the world sort of popping off the way
that it is and captain Adam is really
sort of their ace in the hole insofar as
he's a guy that can go toe-to-toe with
Superman and there's no real knowledge
or guarantee the Superman's actually
survived out there and even if there was
there's no real reason to believe the
Superman would abandon everything and
basically fight on behalf of the
government right Island you have like
Amanda Waller and all those folks
there's no reason to believe that and he
wouldn't and so basically they end up
turning to Captain Atom which being a
powerhouse a man made of living energy
in and of himself is a pretty cool thing
to do now what we also end up finding
out here is that Ray Palmer the atom has
actually gone directly into one of these
monsters more or less one of these
zombies and is essentially analyzing the
whole thing in terms of what's going on
inside of it and so as a result of this
of course Captain Atom is sent out and
basically said hey look try to curtail
the threat as much as you can and he
does the best he can but then suddenly
we end up realizing what's going on and
this is actually a genius move by Tom
Taylor I never would have thought of
this that what ended up happening here
is that when the atom when Ray Palmer
went into this zombie he was immediately
infected right because he was just
exposed to the to the equation and when
that
then he came out as the atom and then
went into Captain Atom which is really
cool it's actually a genius idea and
immediately started infecting it the
difference here is that instead of a
Palmer killing Captain Atom in the
traditional sense what he actually ended
up doing was quote-unquote destabilizing
him right because he's are being made of
living energy so all you have to do is
destabilize him and then suddenly he
just turns into a giant bomb and that's
why I say it's really reminiscent of the
events of Kingdom Come right because in
that story he was ripped open and so it
was like all this atomic energy started
pouring out and that's really what kind
of led to the conclusion of the story
right like captain Adam gets ripped open
Superman flies him into the air as fast
as he can oh sorry I think it's Shazam
who does it uh well any one of the
heroes does it and basically ends up
dying in the process I think and
basically like a kind of Usher's in a
new era of peace for the world but is
it's it's essentially the same thing
like captain Adam is basically going
nuclear he's getting ready to detonate
and kill everyone
and so this it's kind of a cool moment
because then you switch back over to uh
Superman and Green Arrow and the new
Green Lantern if you look at it as each
individual issue it seems like it takes
place over the span of like days or
weeks or something like that but if you
just kind of focus on it in and kind of
look at it as the greater whole almost
like you're reading it in trade it takes
place over the course of hours maybe
five or six hours of house it's like the
beginning of this whole thing and so
when you see it that way no wonder
they're all still hanging out of The
Daily Planet
but of course Superman showing up here
the the real question here is if you go
out there and you just try to start
rescuing people you can be exposed to
like a TV screen or some kind of digital
device and you'll be exposed to the
virus and you'll turn and this is
actually again this is another genius
moment it's a small thing see it's the
small things that make Tom Taylor
stories so cool it's the small little
tidbits that make his story so awesome
because what Superman said is there's no
risk of that because I've been using my
x-ray vision the entire time since this
whole thing popped off and it's like man
that's that's like that's actually
pretty genius right because using his
x-ray vision of course he's able to make
out just enough of the the individuals
costumes or what it is that they're
wearing to know who they are but also
probably just the sound of their voice
different things like that it's small
little things like that as that's why
it's so cool is because it's like they
end up sitting out basically like an SOS
to the world and so you end up finding
out that that like Beast Boy Hawkgirl
Lex Luthor and presumably his sister
Lena like they're alive and it's kind of
like we all need to band together and
try to save the world as best we can
it's a cool moment because then you
switch over to Wonder Woman on the
mascara you know and her talking to to
Hippolyta is just kinda like hey look I
have to do this I can't
stay here yes this is my home and I'm
safe here but like my duty is to protect
the world and of what hero am i if I
don't protect the world and so then you
basically end up having you know having
Superman accompany travel over to
Keystone City and meet with Barry Allen
and meet with Wally West this is a cool
thing because one of the things that
they were told when this whole thing
popped off Batman immediately got a hold
of them and said do not go anywhere go
somewhere where there is no technology
of any kind stay there don't go anywhere
and and it's actually it makes perfect
sense right because if any of the
Flash's if any other speedsters neo
managed to contract this virus the world
would be over like that
there'd be no survivors I mean your talk
about people who can move up to the
speed of light and if they want to enter
the Speed Force at the speed of light uh
and then if they enter the Speed Force
with us who the hell knows what's gonna
happen right so you're talking about
guys who can vibrate from one dimension
to another so it would be it'd be
catastrophic it would take this global
pandemic and elevate it to becoming a
multiversal pandemic the entire
multiverse would just collapse because
of the speedsters vibrating from one
universe to the next and killing
everything they see I love these little
nuggets man I love these little tidbits
it's so cool to see this and so what you
end up getting of course is is basically
like this sound of thunder right it's
kind of emanating and making its way to
them and that's when you actually find
out you find out that this Giganta right
like one of the villains of Wonder Woman
it's just like a Lhasa woman now of
course she's she's dealt with relatively
quick insofar as like you know the
batwing comes flying out of nowhere and
crashes into or at least she grabs it
and then crushes it now of course once
Superman accompanied shows up Superman
manages to knock her down
Wonder Woman actually goes to killer and
this is one of the things I disagree
with with Superman you know Superman's
like no wait you can't kill her yet
Batman said they're only infected so
maybe there's hope and it's like no
Superman they're gone like they're
they're dead man it's time to let go
Supes but I get that you're the boy
scout I get there's always a good
there's always a way but sometimes
there's not Homeslice sometimes there's
nothing you can do and you just gotta
let him go
the cool thing about this is the work
gets done form when sob or blows a hole
in her head now can we just all like
let's look at this for a second all
right
cyborg fans you're finally getting your
do can we all just say this looks badass
cyborg standing behind like like a giant
woman's head and you just blew a hole in
it like can we just say that's amazing
like it looks awesome it really does
like it looks and see this kind of stuff
is why I love comics man because it's
just it's the tits but it's it looks
badass like let's not let's let's take a
moment of silence for how awesome this
is okay so having said that this is
where we kind of get the explanation of
what it is is going on right and in what
side work really kind of clarifies here
of course you do have Alfred who shows
up and makes Damian Wayne the new Batman
now this is a pretty sentimental thing
one of the big things when it came to
Damian assuming that the history between
this version of his character and the
main DC Universe history is that he's
kind of been reforming himself after
being trained to be just like this
heartless assassin you know by by Talia
al Ghul by his biological mother and
yellow sue either that history is still
relatively the same he's always been
trying to work to become the best
version of himself and for Batman to
pass down the mantle to him solidifies a
few things one it solidifies his
father's faith in it Bruce Wayne
believes that Damian is capable of
becoming Batman but it also solidifies
the fact that his father's dead that
there's no coming back for Batman that
he's gone he's out of the picture
there's no other members of the bat
family Damian is the last one left and
that's kind of got to be a crushing
sensation right to sit down like to wake
up one day and realize that like you're
your surrogate brothers and sisters are
all dead that your biological father is
dead everyone you know and love is dead
shy of Alfred he's the only guy left and
and is it's a it's a rough thing to see
right because in the midst of all this
he just cries in the arms of Alfred and
that's its that's what I loved about
this because it's so human right like
Damian Wayne seems to be a kid who's so
disconnected from his humanity and you
see something like this and it's just so
human and it's so cool and III dig like
I love this I love writing like this I
love writing that focuses so much on the
characters the focus is so much on like
who they are kind of at their core and
so that's when cyborg chimes in and says
okay so these guys aren't really dead in
the traditional sense right they're not
like Night of the Living Dead zombies
they're affect similes is all they are
there fact similes of the anti-life
equation that the anti-life equation is
exactly what it stands for anti-life and
they will spread anti-life ie death
everywhere they go now this is Tom
Taylor taking the anti-life equation in
the most literal sense right taking it
and using it for its namesake and saying
the anti-life equation is anti life it
exists to basically replace life with
death and again that flies in the face
of the traditional census so I imagine
there'll be some who is who kind of you
know kind of snub at that and say no no
no that's not what the anti-life
equation is it was never meant to be
that way it just dominates the Wills of
people because that's what Jack Kirby
wanted that's what it needs to be
honestly I don't really care one way or
the other it makes for a cool story but
basically it's cyborg
saying that like they're not human
anymore there's no way to bring them
back you can't fix them you can't save
them there's nothing we can do they will
find life anywhere there is life they
will find it the only way for us to do
that is to leave here is to get out of
here as that's why it's kind of crazy
because in the midst of all this
suddenly they're met by the arrival of
Hawkgirl who says hey look captain Adams
is getting ready to explode he's getting
ready to wipe everything out and so as a
result of this captain Adams as soon as
he soon as he detonates right you got
Wonder Woman you've got Superman they
whisk him up into the air as fast as
they can but when he detonates all of
Washington DC goes with it right so
what's left of the government's gone now
there's no organizing structure or force
anymore there's no real military and if
there is a military they don't know who
they're taking their orders from so
there's no real government left anymore
there's nobody making the decisions all
that stuff's basically gone the outlying
territories Baltimore they're all
basically gone and the last one to be
hit as metropolis and so what this looks
like is seemingly almost everybody's
going to die now if I'm a betting man
I'd probably bet here that basically the
Green Lantern's gonna conjure a shield
that will protect everyone but
essentially what this will mean is that
everybody in their immediate vicinity is
gone all the heroes that were there are
dead all the villains that were there
are dead and they're gonna have to kind
of go back out into the world and see if
they can save who they can but again
this is Tom Taylor and this is Warren
Ellis I would say it's gonna be
unnecessarily bleak and they're all
gonna die these horridly like these
horrendous radiated deaths you know
where they all died of radiation
sickness or something like that this is
Tom Taylor there's usually light at the
end of the tunnel so I'm curious to see
where this goes I'm really excited to
see how this ends
okay so we are getting back into DC
stand here's the thing we actually
missed one of the tie-in stories there's
actually you have the main DC stu title
itself which is six issues and then you
have a good day to die and initially I
didn't really plan on covering a good
day to die
mostly because I didn't read it and then
I sat down and read it and I was like
this is amazing we need to cover this
because deceased itself the main six
issue limited series it deals largely
with the most well known superheroes
right the cool thing about the the good
day to die is it deals with like some
still pretty prominent superheroes but
actually kind of takes it from a
different direction so it's really
really cool the way it goes down so
initially this picks up with scot-free
and big Barda now those you guys who are
unfamiliar with this ring do a lot of
explaining in this for people who are
unfamiliar with it but firfer scot-free
and and big Barda released mister
miracle as a lot of you guys probably
know I'm and big Barda their home is
essentially apocalypse for mister
miracle it was and then sometimes it is
sometimes it's not the way this works in
in DC Comics is you have two worlds more
or less after the events like crisis on
Infinite Earths they were actually in a
singular universe as it exists now and
the new vision - and it's part of DC
rebirth they're actually out there in
their own place really within the
multiverse itself but you end up having
the the planet of apocalypse and the
planet of New Genesis and they're really
designed to kind of represent good and
evil that's how they were designed by
Jack Kirby when he wrote the fourth
world but the idea is that New Genesis
is home to highfather and of course
apocalypse is home to Darkseid and the
initial basis behind this is that the
two groups were basically at war with
each other and so in order to broker a
peace Abbey by the name of Metatron came
along and basically had them swap sons
so so essentially the son of hi father
went over to went to apocalypse and the
son of apocalypse went to New Genesis
and so as a result it was a way to
basically keep the peace so that neither
would destroy the other's world in by
virtue of that kill their own sons with
scot-free would hit with him going over
to apocalypse he basically does a live
like this really crappy life where he
was in a Cell all the time eventually he
learned how to pick the lock and because
this the the locks for a hawk that was
so difficult to pick ultimately it meant
that he basically became like the best
lock picker ever but nonetheless big
Bart it was part of the Furies and the
fury was basically like an all-female
team with some occasional guys in there
that served as a special II like agents
of apocalypse and were trained by granny
goodness it was a pretty cool idea but
essentially these two folks are
basically like okay like Darkseid's dead
apocalypse has been destroyed now we got
to leave now there is no reference here
to new Genesis there's no reference to
it we can assume it exists I mean the
two kind of exists in opposite poles to
one another but
no reference to it so we can just kind
of you know roll with that but what it
does is it switches over to Michael Holt
also known as mr. terrific now again mr.
terrific is one of the smartest people
in the world I think he's probably in
the top three but mr. terrific has
basically been conducting experiments on
Captain Boomerang right like an infected
person he's an exposed him to another
dose of the virus to see if there's any
kind of change
there's no stimulus no response to being
touched or anything like that so
essentially he's just sort of a nonhuman
entity right like whatever sense of
humanity he had his long since been gone
now so where you wind up having
scot-free and Barda who go back to their
apartment they end up getting a knock on
the door this is where the reasons why I
love Scott free right because he's a
humorous character if he's written
correctly like he's supposed to be he's
hilarious and initially like he makes
this comment like when they hear a knock
at the door it's like whoa maybe
somebody with like a bloody stump I have
no earthly clue of course once they
answer it it turns out to be mr.
terrific but as one of these things
where he's essentially been analyzing
the the whole situation now of course
this is a role that would normally be
reserved for Batman but as we know Bruce
Wayne's basically dead he's he's out of
the picture now and so because of this
Michael Holt's been trying to deduce and
trying to figure out what's going on and
ultimately his initial idea was if the
virus originated from apocalypse that we
can travel there and we can basically
try to find a cure no guarantees there
but now it's basically out the window
because apocalypse has been completely
destroyed and so following that their
response is well then we only have one
other real choice that we can use we can
basically try to invoke like the powers
of magic and so what it does is it
transitions over to court industries
with Booster Gold and with with with Ted
Kord himself the Blue Beetle now again
this is kind of a cool thing but this is
somebody else's sort of interesting here
is because of the nature of the
situation and the nature of the story
normally we would expect Tom Taylor to
write Booster Gold
not so much in in a goofball way I mean
he really is kind of a goofy character
but we would expect him to be written in
a way where he's more of like not only
the comic relief but something close to
it and this he's not written that way
now the cool thing about that this is
one of the reasons why so many fans love
Booster Gold is because depending on
who's writing the story he can be a very
dynamic character if it's a rider that
doesn't really care anything about him
he's done in a throwaway fashion Mike's
just kinda like here's the guy who's a
goofball he's a buffoon and you throw
him away that way but if he's written
effectively he can be one of the more
dynamic characters in the entirety of of
DC right because he's the guy that
everybody knows is basically a dude from
the future who went to the Past and
essentially faked being a hero from the
future in order to try to be a hero in
the present day because he was a loser
in the future he's always kind of kind
of a chip on his shoulder but in this
instance it's one of these pretty
hardcore situations because with
everything sort of popping off the way
that it is the response is like we
basically need you guys like like we
need you Booster Gold in order to help
us you know achieve this particular goal
but before we do this we're gonna see we
can't find a way to cure it with magic
and so of course what they end up doing
is traveling to England and we pick up
with John Constantine now the funny
thing about this is that magic in DC is
is sort of intriguing whether those are
guys who were reading DC rebirth' right
now or I guess really it's DC Universe
now there was a big reference to to how
magic works right especially in Doomsday
Clock that initially magic was just a
thing that existed in DC and it kind of
had some some ties to a bit of reality
warping and it was also sort of tried
and true Witchcraft and Wizardry what
dr. Manhattan revealed by virtue of
Doomsday Clock is that all people who
were doing when they manipulate magic is
they're essentially manipulating reality
but on a much smaller scale and they're
doing it with what are essentially the
leftovers of the various properties of
the universe that are out there but the
fact remains here that is kind of being
treated in this situation or at least
being viewed by mr. terrific it's kind
of a catch-all right like if we have
people who can use magic we can just
sort of wish it all away and everything
will be okay and then everything would
be fine that'll be it you know of course
picking up with Constantine we learned
that's not the case and the reason why
is because of this guy fleeing for his
life if magic could easily be used or
could be channeled in a way to where it
could essentially solve solve all the
problems well then all it would take is
like dr. fate and cetana
and a handful of other people probably
Ettrick in to come along with
Constantine and then go from city to
city snapping their fingers and
everything will be okay or one great big
huge giant spell that they create in
order to cure the world and everything
would be done in like one issue but with
Constantine fleeing for his life like
this and then ultimately how need to
incinerate his best friend Chas who's
been converted it really kind of shows
us that like there's no real hope here
and that's what Constantine tells mr.
terrific right when terrific shows up
and says hey look like essentially like
we need magic in order to basically cure
this the response of Constantine is like
what do you think I can do just snap my
fingers and everything is fixed buddy if
I could have done that I would have done
it a long time ago it doesn't work that
way like magic doesn't work that way and
and even if it did these folks can't be
saved in that fashion they're not human
anymore the only thing you can really do
is kill them and so as a results of this
because magic is not an option they move
on to Plan C and that involves Booster
Gold basically going back in time and
appealing in the timestream in order to
keep the initial infection from breaking
out and so
everybody essentially shows up here and
then all hell breaks loose as soon as
they arrive right you got like big Barda
and scot-free who basically fall they
end up dying or at least being consumed
by the zombies once Ted Kord and once
mr. terrific and Booster Gold to get
inside this room they're immediately met
by wave rider now wave rider is an
old-school character well not super
old-school B's relatively old school he
appear back in 1991 with a story called
Armageddon 2001 and the idea behind this
story as it was written by Archie
Goodwin is it was basically designed to
kind of show like possible futures right
it was the first real instance of DCE
basically portraying the possibility of
time travel and even even sort of
invoking to a degree the aspect of
Hypertime which would later be sort of
evolved even more by Mark Waid and N and
Grant Morrison but sort of showing like
possible futures for the various
characters that were out there now it
was a to issue miniseries with a whole
bunch of clients to it but Waverider was
basically a guy who came from a future
where some hero in the modern day would
basically go forward ended up killing
all the superheroes and his goal was to
prevent that and so after learning how
to are really being endowed with the
ability to manipulate the time stream
this led to him becoming the character
over a wave rider and then becoming one
of the linear men and the linear men are
basically like like time police is
really what they are like their job is
to monitor the time stream and to make
sure nobody does anything that's
supposed to screw stuff up and this is a
really smart move by Tom Taylor because
the reality is that DC's as it's written
is exceedingly good and in truth Tom
Taylor would have essentially just kind
of pissed it all away
had it turned into a situation where
time-travel everything's fixed it really
goes into a scenario where the Waverider
says you cannot manipulate the time
stream like this is the fate of your
universe you can't escape this this is
how it's supposed to unfold sorry about
your luck I don't know what to tell you
like it's kind of funny the way plays
out it's kind of messed up the way it
plays out but initially Constantine
didn't want to have anything to do with
this right he's like you guys go off and
do your own thing I'm gonna go teleport
to some place I'm gonna find a bar and
I'm just gonna get drunk until
everything around us comes crashing down
and so as a result of this you know
there really doesn't really seem to be
an alternative or an ability to stop
Waverider right I mean you're talking
about a guy who can manipulate quantum
energy he could incinerate Ted Kord and
Booster Gold white that's right in the
blink of an eye and his jaw here even is
to basically arrest Booster Gold and
take him back to the future and so
because of this John Kazin team sitting
in this bar basically sort of recants
and says okay fine gotta go be a hero
right I mean his conscience gets the
better of him and so as a result of that
he shows up he headbutts Waverider
and then basically says I'll hold him
off
only for the entire group to be met with
the arrival of big Barda who literally
rips mr. terrific in half which is kind
of insane to see and so all you really
have left is Booster Gold Blue Beetle
then you got Constantine holding off
Waverider is best he can't but because
of the fact that Michael Holt had been
killed and because of the fact that in
the next part of this video that we're
gonna talk about here in a second that
in events taking place and we'll cover
that you know once we get to it that
basically the future where Booster Gold
comes from doesn't exist anymore
humanity as it exists in his timeline is
gone and so because of that it's kind of
cool to see that like linear time is
maintained meaning that whatever happens
in the present day affects the future is
an absolute outcome essentially Booster
Gold ceases to be he basically fades
from existence and so as a result of
that there's no real means to travel
back in time and to fix everything and
then of course in response to that
Constantine Bond's himself to Waverider
and basically says where you go I go
there's no way for you to escape from me
but the problem with that is that
basically wave riders out of the picture
now wave riders been destroyed because
he's killed by Ted Kord and so again
it's a really good way for Tom Taylor to
kind of say hey we're gonna use time
travel no we're not and then just move
on to the next thing
Nick is following that with it all kind
of going belly-up and all the plans and
really all these superheroes being
killed suddenly you have the arrival of
Zatanna dr. fate Bobo and a couple a
couple other people who basically say
hey look like this world is doomed
there's nothing you can do here come
with us and we're just gonna move on to
a better place and wait for whatever
happens next and the response of
Constantine is not a chance the world
doesn't end until I say it does and so
at this point we switch over to decease
number 5 itself and this is one of the
really cool things because what it does
is it shows the response of humanity in
the process of how all this went down
specifically the government's and what
it shows us is that like all the major
released some of those you know three of
the major cities in the US have been
totally obliterated Washington d.c
Baltimore and metropolis totally
incinerated and completely gone and it's
kind of crazy to see because the Green
Lantern was able to save a handful of
people here in there but for the most
part virtually everybody in Metropolis
is dead and one of the crazy things
about this and it's one of the coolest
moments in the story you know finding
out that Lex Luthor is alive and where
Superman shows up on his doorstep you
know shows up there with the intention
of kind of being like what's one more
dead body Lex Luthor
actually breaks down and it's a great
moment here it's insanely cool the way
it's written because when you have these
two guys you know that the battles
between Lex Luthor and Superman are
timeless right there's some of the
greatest conflicts you're ever going to
see because it's the mind of Lex Luthor
against the Brawn
Superman right and despite how smart
Superman is it usually comes down to a
physical altercation although sometimes
it does sort of focus on battles of the
mind but here Lex Luthor just sort of
begins to cry and just says like look
what happened to our city and that's the
most important you know the most
important takeaway here is that more
important than any one of these two guys
is their allegiance how much they die
you the city of Metropolis because it's
their home and so it's a it's a
beautiful moment here because they have
common ground our entire city has been
totally obliterated all we really have
left is each other
and so what Tom Taylor does is give us a
kind of timeline and say over the course
of the next few days and then the next
few weeks various efforts are undertaken
in order to sort of try to save what's
left of humanity right like all these
various servers are destroyed by the
flash all around the world so the
Internet is taken down as best as it can
be you end up having like mass
satellites that are out there that are
broadcasting you know TV shows or radio
signals or whatever it is those are
taken out by Wonder Woman all these
things are basically implemented by the
superheroes in order to take down modern
technology not only that what they also
need is a refuge right because if Earth
is almost completely overrun then what's
left of humanity that has not been
infected needs a place to stay otherwise
it's only a matter of time before
they're completely destroyed and so what
it does is it leads to Wonder Woman
traveling to Paradise Island and
basically saying like we'd to house
people here and for the most part this
is a big no-no right Paradise Island is
cut off from everything like it's one of
these things were sort of like no one
comes here people aren't allowed to be
here we don't let men onto our island
it's just something you don't do is
something that you just don't see and
it's kind of a cool theme because in
response to this Wonder Woman's
statement is basically I'm a protector
of Earth I'm here to protect the world
and if humanity has fallen as fast and
there's superheroes around there and
superheroes have fallen how long do you
really think it'll be before people show
up here and so in order to basically
keep this place protected as best we can
one we need to have individuals out
there who are who are innocents who did
nothing wrong and are just cut in the
hole you know caught up in the whole
circumstance we need to be able to house
them here because it's the right thing
to do and to really take what's left of
the superhero community and provide some
measure of protection right because
we're the Amazons are powerful at the
end of the day if you're talking about a
vast amount of an infected or somehow
find their way they're talking about
just like a battle of attrition and so
as a result of that you end up having
Green Lantern's Superman and Wonder
Woman who essentially lift the island up
a little bit higher and then you go to
Gotham and you get one of the coolest
moments in the whole story right because
what you end up learning is that over
the course of a week an entire jungle
grew throughout the entire city of
Gotham and of course that's when you
meant
that is poison ivy that made that happen
now of course Killer Croc tries to
attack you know Batman and and and and
Green Arrow and Dinah Lance the new the
new Green Lantern tries to attack him
he's taken out you know by poison ivy
less we end up learning poison ivy used
her power of the dream to create a kind
of safe haven in the entirety of Gotham
but the funny thing about this is the
only people allowed in are the people
she allows in and at the moment it only
really seems to be Harley Quinn and in
poison ivy herself and Harley is this
kind of a cool moment Harley has
actually been advocating to turning it
into a refuge and saying look like you
have all this stuff here right like
you've grown vines here and there's this
great big huge thorn wall and like none
of the undead can get in here so I can
let innocent people in and for the most
part poison ivy does it really seem to
have want to do it but then when you
have Batman everybody's showing up and
you have Damian Wayne basically saying
look Bruce Wayne's dead right like my
father's dead I'm the new Batman now
poison ivy begins to kind of feel form
because it really is a kind of
realization of how bad things are
and so as a result of that knowing that
Bruce Wayne is gone knowing that Damian
Wayne is taking up the mantle and
realizing things are really just this
dire ultimately poison ivy gives in and
the response is you know of course don't
harm any of the trees or anything like
that and Damian Wayne answers like we'll
agree to any terms and so what it does
is it switches over to the fortress of
solitude
now the fortress of solitude itself is
not really big enough to house all these
innocent people otherwise I would have
said like why not turn that place into a
refuge it wasn't designed for that right
it's just simply not that big but it is
big enough to become a new Hall of
Justice right for what's left of the
superhero community to essentially work
together and it's kind of a cool moment
here because you have all these folks
basically gathered around saying here's
where things stand
you've got firestorm Ronnie Raymond
you've got Power Girl you've got a lot
of these superheroes here who are
basically doing the best they can to
sort of keep everything under control to
keep their heads level you got Lex
Luthor who's starting some nonsense but
one of the big things is basically being
worked on here is the creation of arcs
and the creation of arcs are a really
cool idea because basically what it
means is it allows humanity released it
seems to allow humanity to basically
sort of finding a way to escape and it's
kind of crazy because initially the
response to Superman is we're not
leaving we're not going to leave this
planet we're not going to abandon our
home and Lex think they're sort of
chimes in it's just kind of like you
know the human race is in it isn't like
a fight to survive but it has to leave
the planet and it's kind of interesting
because these are two opposing
ideologies for Lex Luthor earth is his
home right but it's kind of like in
order for Humanity survive we have to
leave here we have to go someplace else
but Superman
his home right his home was destroyed
before he was old enough to really do
anything about it and one of the big on
running themes about Superman is trying
to find a way to maintain his home
trying to find a way to either reconnect
with Krypton or protect earth as best he
can and there's got to be a little bit
of guilt here if Earth is destroyed that
it's like Superman failed right in the
idea of him failing and losing another
home is really too much for him to deal
with and so it's kind of like we can't
simply just leave here but in the end
you end up having like the mom of
Superman and you know coming in Marth
they're basically coming in and saying
hey look it's the only real choice that
we have they're able to kind of talk him
down a little bit now of course Lex
Luthor basically achons and you know
like man losing two worlds in a lifetime
it sucks to be you Lois Lane punches the
heck out of him it's hilarious and she
puts a haymaker on him
and then she sees Jonathan when he when
she realizes that he saw what she did
and he's like aah violence is never the
answer Jonathan and that that's true
violence is never the answer that is a
very true that is a very true statement
however violence is a answer it is a
very effective answer right like
violence gets things done and so it's
it's it's kind of crazy because with
these arcs basically being built as a
means to get humanity off the off the
face of the planet and with these
various refuges serving as a place for
Humanity to reside until that time it
really starts to give people hope it
gives people the ability and really the
belief that there's other places they
can go to my community we are communing
with a Green Lantern ring saying like
where are other places we can go but
ultimately what they end up realizing is
that none of them were ever in control
and the reason why is because while all
this is going down suddenly they're met
with this kind of buzzing sound and then
it begins to get louder and louder and
begins to drive them insane only for us
to find out that when Lex Luthor dies
this is the Martian Manhunter and the
Martian Manhunter is infected now this
is a big deal and the reason why is
because if you go and you read the JLA
stories by Grant Morrison one of the
things that DC shows and actually states
in in multiple instances is that the
Martian Manhunter is the most powerful
being on earth he has all the abilities
of Superman plus he can shape-shift and
he can read minds right now he is afraid
of fire you know as well
sometimes he is sometimes he's not it's
just a weakness whatever the case is but
like fire is basically the best way to
combat it but having a somebody out
there who can shape-shift into pretty
much anything and then suddenly show up
and attack the entirety of the superhero
community almost guarantees destruction
for all of them however they have Ronnie
Raymond on their side they have
firestorm who of course uses his powers
and Talia's incinerates Martian
Manhunter the
problem with this is that when that
happens the flash Barry Allen is
attacked and he's infected and this is
probably the worst case situation
because he immediately takes off running
and the reason why this is bad is
because you're talking about the fastest
man alive who can basically infect the
world and he does it in the blink of an
eye almost no survivors are left
basically he just like runs around from
place to place before they even realize
there's anybody there
they're infected you know and it's it's
insane how fast it happens and so
Superman isthat responds by saying hey
look I can't really catch up with him
but I can meet him on the other side and
this is one of the coolest things
because what do you does basically fly
out you know to the moon and then fly
back as fast as he possibly can and
basically crash directly into Barry
Allen and where Barry Allen's totally
destroyed in the process he's cut in
half the issue with this is that some of
the bones end up ripping into Superman
so now he's infected and is one of the
saddest moments ever because what this
means is the world is doomed there's no
escape here humanity has Rashed and
humanity to try to escape but Superman
could eradicate those things in the
blink of an eye a guy who could fly into
space and hold his breath for a pretty
lengthy amount of time and then of
course has all those powers based on the
abilities of solar radiation is is
insanely cool the only way to really get
around this would be to like retrofit
the various ships with like green
kryptonite but you would have to do it
in such a way to where the area of
effect of that green kryptonite is so
far out the Superman can't even get
remotely close but you're talking about
a guy with telescopic vision so he could
be far enough away that he could use his
heat vision and then shoot them and then
destroy them right so I mean it's kind
of nuts now ultimately the goal is
Superman seemingly you know seeming as
an infected person would be to spread
the infection not necessarily just kill
people and so if Tom Taylor stays true
to what he's been doing so far
then retrofitting the ships with green
kryptonite is the only real hope they
have but at the moment they don't really
seem to have any because as they sort of
look around Superman starts meeting with
everybody he knows his fates his fate is
sealed and everybody else does too
Lois really says her goodbyes and and
she's like you know thank you for
choosing me and it's it's such an
incredibly touching moment thank you for
choosing me thank you for making this
place your home thank you for loving me
and it's kind of crushing because in
turn he speaks to John and says like
you're the one running the show now
you're the man of the house now like you
have to make sure everybody stays safe
the fate of humanity rests on your
shoulders and it seems like it'd be a
huge amount of pressure to bestow on a
child and it is but it's also the
reality of the situation that's really
what's going on here is that it really
all
does come down to Jonathan but that's
why I love DC so much is because this is
things just getting insanely dire things
are getting really really bad because
what's basically happened here is that
now that Martian Manhunter is gone the
most powerful superhuman in the world is
infected and that's literally what's
said here is that with with the
infection of Superman hope was gone
along with the entirety of the world
that there's no real saving anybody
anymore okay so we are at the conclusion
of deceased and here's the thing
deceased is an amazing story it's
ridiculous how good it is and to be
honest I wasn't sure was gonna be this
great right I was kind of on the fence
[Music]
but Tom Taylor does what Tom Taylor
always does which has come out in
spectacular fashion right so in the last
video we basically ended with Superman
being infected and it was like okay so
this is basically the end of everybody
right like nobody's gonna make it out
alive here because you're talking about
the Man of Steel like the most powerful
superhero on earth after the Martian
Manhunter and the Martian Manhunter was
already destroyed that the crazy thing
about this is is it's almost it's it's
incredible the way this is done because
it kind of parallels Superman as we know
him as a superhero in comparison to
Superman in terms of what's actually
going on right so it's like you know
faster than a speeding bullet more
powerful than a locomotive able to leap
tall buildings in a single bound the
amazing man who's gonna kill you all
it's Superman but it's crazy because the
way this narration is taught is like all
hope was lost at 11:48 a.m. and it's
kind of nuts because what we end up
doing is jumping over to the fortress of
solitude right which is where basically
the last of the superheroes are all
essentially gathered together it's cool
to see Tom Taylor do this because what
they end up doing is really Damian Wayne
kind of pops up and says Batman always
had a kind of back-up plan always has a
plan to basically deal with superheroes
and it turns out it was for pretty much
everybody except uh Green Arrow
Green Arrow was kind of disappointed
because he's like that man didn't have a
plan for me he didn't really consider me
dangerous and it's like now a green
arrow I'm sorry man now one of the
things that I want to kind of point out
here is a Damian Wayne it's not really a
huge thing but Damian Wayne never refers
to himself as Batman Damian Wayne always
says like well he always you first a
Batman is a wholly different person
right like Batman had plans like he's
just kind of a stand-in right there he's
not really Batman
he's just temporarily taking his place
it's interesting there because it shows
that one Damian Wayne is not accepted
the fact that his father's actually dead
and two Damian Wayne does not see him
self as being Batman in the same way
that Bruce Wayne was in so far as he's
not really as good of a Batman is Bruce
was which it's kind of a true statement
but it's also it's also a great little
kind of tribute to Bruce himself and so
in addition to that we also end up
learning that of course Damian Wayne has
a piece of Kryptonite on him because you
know how else you gonna defeat Superman
and then also diana is the one like
Wonder Woman is one who's been kind of
sitting down and saying we have to find
like miles don't have schemes and I have
ideas on how to take down these various
superheroes and so what she ends up
doing is taking this kryptonite and
merging it with essentially metal and
then crafting a sword out of it which is
a genius idea because when it comes to
Wonder Woman here's the important thing
to understand about Wonder Woman I
wouldn't go as far as to say that people
sleep on her that she's like less she
says she's a character there's it's kind
of like nobody really appreciates how
capable she is but Wonder Woman fights
to the end that's the nature of her
character she fights threats head-on she
doesn't really rest on her laurels and
kind of wait to see how things unfold
and so at the same time the idea here is
okay and this is gonna be the case then
basically we take the various guys and
we fall back right like we fall back as
best we can we're gonna take one group
they're all gonna head to Gotham they're
gonna grab as many of those survivors as
they possibly can and they can only grab
like a small number of them right like a
very very small number of them
comparatively speaking
and then basically head out right so the
end up going to Gotham and their guide
as many of the survivors as they can and
then they go to they go to end up going
to the mascara to try to grab as many of
the survivors as they possibly can the
problem is that once this arc arrives at
the mascara they don't arrive alone and
it's actually one of the coolest things
that go on here's when the coolest
things that happens there's this tempest
this massive storm that takes place
outside of the island and when
everybody's kind of gathering around
waiting to see what it is ultimately
it's the arrival of Aquaman who summoned
the Kraken and this is one of the
coolest things in the whole story right
because it's like Aquaman should like
Aquaman here's the thing about Aquaman
I've until Dan Abnett wrote the
character as part of like DC rebirth I
never I was never really interested in
it I was gonna like Aquaman is a guy
who's there and he talks to fish and
Aquaman fans hate it when you say that
but it's true but like when you read Dan
Abbott's run on Aquaman it's like one of
the greatest Aquaman epics that I think
that I've ever read either in hindsight
or or having read more recently but like
seeing Aquaman show up here with like an
entire army of Atlanteans that in turn
is channeling the Kraken is a sight to
behold with the first question that I
had here is how is he able to find
famous spirit because the mists akyurek
is an island that cannot be found except
by those who already know where it is
but then like Tom Taylor answers this in
a like with a quickness what he says is
that under normal circumstance
no the mascara cannot be found instead
what ended up happening here is that
when famous Kira was turned into an
island its boundaries were expanded in
order to make way for all these refugees
it took it out of its safe zone and it
just brought it into the main world
right land to the main DC Universe which
technically was always kind of the case
there's this kind of dimensional barrier
that sort of permeates and exists around
thermosphere that keeps people from
finding it that was removed when they
essentially turn it into a haven for
anybody to be able to access and so
because of that it was easily found by
Aquaman and all of his forces and they
just come rolling in here and tearing
everything up Green Arrow gets his due
which is kind of cool here because he
shoots an arrow through the eye or
through the head of Aquaman and he's
like you see I'm dangerous I shot an
arrow half a mile through like raging
winds and then hit a guy in the head but
basically it's calling in everybody they
can right so a cassie sandsmark Wonder
Girl is already here uh you end up
having like all these Amazons
that end up charging directly into the
fray I can see Atlanteans and then half
a world away
you've got Wonder Woman that you've got
the new Green Lantern Dino lance and
you've got cyborg who go charging in
against Superman and the cool thing
about this is this is like a colossal
fight and scale right I mean this is
really a fight to save the world it's
really what this is if Superman wins the
Ark's will fall if the Amazons lose the
arc in Atlantis will fall there's
massive casualties on each side and the
struggling thing about this for the
Amazons right the biggest struggle about
this is you're talking about a
sisterhood these are women who have
fought together for for eons right who
have fought together as friends or lived
together as friends for eons and eons
and eons right imagine that you had a
friend that you'd known for like a
thousand years and then imagine like
that you had to kill him rightly they
turned against you and seemingly the
blink of an eye and that's what's going
on here is like these are our allies
that have fought together forever and
then suddenly they turn into enemies
when they're bitten and they're
converted into these you know undead
anti-life zombies and so it's kind of
crazy because what ends up happening
here is basically once all these
refugees are onto the arts and it's like
we have to go we've got to bail we can't
stay here if we do this art is going to
be destroyed and so the order comes down
from Hippolyta the leader of the Amazons
who says flee get out of here leave us
here like those of us who are not on the
ark leave us here we'll fight it will
hold off as best we can but essentially
their sacrifice to their life is a
suicide mission you're talking about
with what amounts to at this point maybe
three four possibly five Amazon's
pulling off an army of of Atlanteans
it's not gonna happen right and so
ultimately we're kind of left with the
idea that like all these differ
these different Amazon's basically end
up falling and the art makes it to
safety following that and this is kind
of a cool moment following that you kind
of switch back to Superman and the and
here's the thing about Dinah Lance as
the Green Lantern she's capable but the
issue with her as a Green Lantern is she
doesn't really have the experience that
the other Green Lantern's do she's
literally flying by the seat of her
pants
so creating like a giant horn and then
doing her her canary cry into the horn
and then just like blowing it into
Superman that's cool but in order to be
an effective Green Lantern what you need
is finesse you need the ability to
understand how to bob and weave how to
dodge various targets now at the same
time you are also talking about a super
fast guy who's astronomically strong so
it's not an easy feat it's not an easy
thing but the issue with this is a
Superman almost gets the upper hand on
Black Canary and almost kills her until
his arm is cut off by Wonder Woman the
problem with this is that while Wonder
Woman does get the upper hand on
Superman for a moment without hesitation
he takes out Wonder Woman and that's
what made Superman so dangerous as this
this zombie monster thing is because in
doing that Superman is he's not
hesitating here like he wants to kill
the imperative drive that he has to kill
and destroy as much as he possibly can
and so there's there's it's not like oh
my god I'm getting ready to kill
Wunderland it's not like that it's da
BAM and then just like punches a hole in
her and that's basically the end of that
it's a crazy thing to kind of see
because with Wonder Woman basically out
of the picture now immediately Superman
takes off and starts going after the
arch and this is when you get to what's
probably the greatest point in the story
right like the greatest moment this
story it's quick because basically like
the arcs have made it off of Earth right
they're out there by the moon they're on
there they're essentially on their way
out God Tom Taylor is so amazing at this
this is why I want to see I want to see
DC's to continue which you know well
we'll talk about to talk about that once
we get to the end but like they get
outside of Earth they're over there by
the moon they're basically taking off
and you've got Jonathan and you've got
Damien standing on one of the arcs and
Jonathan's like my father's coming and
Damien's like yeah you're your dad's on
his way it's not some grandiose gesture
it's nothing like that it's just like
tell my mom I love her and look after
her and then like he basically tells
Lois like I know what I'm doing
everything is gonna be okay I promise I
know what I'm doing and then he just
leave the ship and goes to confront his
dad the issue with this is this like a
moment right like like Superman's
charging towards you arcs like Jonathan
Kim goes charging towards Superman and
in a moment is able to basically knock
him unconscious and that's basically it
that's all that we get but this is why
this moment is so cool and this
why this moment matters so much is
because this is Jonathan Kent right this
is what we would expect from the son of
Superman we would expect the son of
Superman to understand that what's
important here is the valuation of life
that this man is not his father this man
used to be his father but it's not his
father now and his task the last thing
his father assigned him was to ensure
the safety of everyone and that's the
choice Jonathan has to make is racing in
in fighting his dad which is a crushing
situation right like if he killed
Superman it be patricide but it's a cool
thing to see because it's like this is
what he has to do at the same time like
for the most part it's a stopgap measure
he's really what it what it appears to
be because at the end of the day despite
how capable Jonathan is he's not on the
same level as his father and so once
Superman comes to then presumably the
fight would continue but Jonathan likely
wouldn't be able to end it but none of
that matters because wild wild Dinah
Lance is sitting out do this wise love
Tom Taylor
well Dinah Lance is sitting out there
right she suddenly hears attention Green
Lantern of sector to 81 for the cavalry
has arrived and the entire Green Lantern
Corps comes racing in with ganthet and
the guardians of the universe and it's
like dude it is the coolest thing it's
like one of the greatest things ever
because like okay so like they're
basically all saved because there's no
way Superman could overcome every single
one of these Green Lantern's and that's
really kind of how it goes right plus
they have ganthet who would be more than
enough to destroy Superman just in his
current form and so what is happening is
they're just kind of standoff for a
second why Superman just kind of stands
there just sort of looks you know and
tries to figure out how it is that he
can destroy these guys and like yeah
that initially holds off if Superman
goes racing into the Sun and it's like
what in the hell is he doing it was like
he's feeding he's absorbing the energy
of the Sun and basically that's when
everything kind of gets cut off and
that's when they're like we have to
leave and the reason why is because if
Superman drains out all that solar
energy than one he's probably gonna be
God - you're powerful right like
Superman 1 million powerful but at the
same time is gonna kill all life on
earth because while the earth while the
earth does have heat inside of it by a
virtue of like the ozone layer that heat
won't last forever is it's like having a
warm house and then cutting off your
heat eventually that heat is gonna
dissipate through the windows and
ultimately your house if you give it
long enough is going to become as cold
as the outside or pretty close to it and
so as a result of that the earth is
basically doomed and that's basically
what they say is like the Green
Lantern's the guardians of the universe
our quarantine earth they're basically
cutting earth off and so like
everybody's
they gotta go like there's there's
there's no seam in the planet anymore
because there's no way to sustain life
on the planet anymore so all those
humans who were left behind are all
guaranteed to die there's no rescuing
them there's no getting them out and so
it kind of sucks here because what you
end up doing is jamming back to earth
itself and where cyborg has managed to
use the lasso of truth around Wonder
Woman this is actually genius by Tom
Taylor like he comes to this realization
the lasso of truth compels you to speak
the truth right so we asked wonderful do
you have a voice can you speak and she
referred she said it says yes we have a
voice right so what this indicates is
that these zombies these anti-life
monsters more or less have a hive mind
and so following that the question
becomes is there a cure is there a way
to end this virus because it's basically
what it is like you're still be just a
viral infection is there a way to end it
and the response is yes there is a way
to end it so when cyborg asks like
what's the way to cure this the response
is that the cure is in you like you're
the only way to cure this thing you're
the cause of all that's right like your
man in machine you are the the way by
which the vector by which this was
spread that it was a it was a
mathematical equation that spread from
your machine components into your human
element and then spread throughout the
rest of the world the problem with this
is that where cyber begins to panic and
realizes hey I need to tell somebody
what's going on I need to go tell the
people on the arch Wonderwoman rips his
head off so no one knows that there's a
cure for this thing no one knows that
there's a cure for this for this
infection and so ultimately what you end
up having is is the guardians of the
universe who guide the Earthlings back
to their new home which they dub of
Earth - which is a cool little nod to
the earth - conduit II and basically
this story ends but here's what I want
to know is like if Superman was
absorbing all that energy from the Sun
what happens to Superman right like what
goes on with that that's why stories
like this are cool is because it's kind
of left open-ended a possibility for a
sequel to emerge or at the very least
just kind of letting us as the as the as
the reader sort of answer that question
on our own kind of descent into debates
and different things like that but
without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here - comments explain make sure
you guys at the sub-1 to become part of
the rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]